find the volume of a cube with a side
length of 8 x y squared so we have a
cube right here and they're saying that
each of the sides for a cube all of the
sides have the same length each of them
have length 8 x y squared so the length
of this side maybe we call this the
width is 8
x
y squared
the length of this side maybe we can
call that the depth or the length
depending on how you want to label it is
8 x y squared the height
of this cube the height of this cube
well is also going to be 8 x y squared a
cube all of the dimensions are the same
now if you want to take the volume of
any rectangular prism you'll multiply
these three dimensions you'll multiply
the width times the depth times the
height now in a cube these are all the
same dimensions so you can just take
this dimension and multiply it by itself
three times or you could take it to the
third power so the volume of this cube
the volume of this cube is
eight
x
y squared i could just multiply it by
itself three times or i could say well
or to the
third power that's why raising something
to the third power is called cubing it
because you're essentially finding the
volume of a cube where the thing that
you're cubing is the dimension of each
of the sides now what's this going to be
well when you take a product and you
raise it to some power you can if you
that's the same thing as taking each of
the terms to that power so this is the
same thing as 8 to the third power
times
x
to the third power
times x to the third power
times
y squared to the third power times y
squared
to the third power and what's 8 to the
third power that's the same thing as
sixty eight squared is sixty-four so
we'll multiply sixty-four times eight
sixty-four times eight four times eight
is thirty-two
six times eight is forty-eight plus
three is fifty-one so it's 512. so this
is equal to 512
times x to the third
x to the third and y squared to the
third power that's the same thing as y
to the 2 times 3 power or y to the sixth
power
or y to the sixth power
y to the sixth power and we're done we
found the volume of the cube it's 512 x
to the third
y to the sixth